we've already seen several videos where
we one learned what the Pythagorean
theorem is and how it can be applied to
find the sides of right triangles and
even to find the distances between
points on the Cartesian plane so this
the Pythagorean theorem and just as a
bit of a review it tells us that if I
have a right triangle if I have a right
triangle and if C is the side opposite
the right angle right that's my right
angle C is that side it's the longest
side we called that the hypotenuse
hypotenuse I'll write the whole word hi
pot hi pot in use then the square of the
other sides the sum of the squares of
the other side will be equal to C
squared so if this side is a this side
is B the Pythagorean theorem tells us
that a squared plus B squared is going
to be equal to C squared and we did
several problems where we use this to
solve different triangles what I want to
show you in this video is really a
visual you can view it as a visual proof
of the Pythagorean theorem to see why
this actually makes sense and to
understand that I'm going to draw a
little bit of a diagram here so let's
let me draw a little right triangle here
so let's say that that is my right
triangle and let's say that this is a
this is B that is my right angle then
that right there this right here that
length right there is C now what I'm
going to do is draw this exact same
triangle but I'm going to rotate it a
little bit you're going to see what I'm
talking about this right here is the
exact same triangle that I just drew
except I rotated it so this is a this is
B and now this is C you this is the
exact you could you could do this you
know you could you could take a ruler
out and actually do it in a you know
pick up the a B and C and you can
actually get you just rotate this
triangle around to the right like this
you could just rotate it like that and
you would get this triangle right just
like that now I'm going to rotate it
again I'm going to rotate it again and
I'm just going to
you can imagine copy and pasting it and
then I will get this triangle I will get
that triangle just like that and once
again this is a this is B and this is C
these are all these triangles are all
the exact same triangle the exact same
measure now let me rotate this again and
I'll get this triangle I will get I will
get this triangle right here and once
again this is a this length right here
is a this length right here is B and
this is the hypotenuse of this right
angle this is C now what do we have here
what do we have here we have all of
these right angles and inside I have
this other square that is inscribed into
this right angle and I can prove to you
if you like that these are also these
are also right angles and you know why
don't I just show it to you you might
you may or may not already be familiar
that the angles in a triangle add up to
180 so if you call if you call this
angle X you call this angle Y we know
that X plus y plus 90 degrees have to be
equal to 180 so X plus y plus 90 have to
be equal to 180 or you could say that if
you subtract 90 from both sides of this
equation X plus y are going to be equal
to 90 I just subtracted 90 from both
sides this disappears 180 minus 90 is 90
and this x and y they're all over if
this angle is X right here so is this
angle because the exact same triangle so
is this angle so is this angle if this
angle is y so is that angle so is that
angle and so is that angle now you may
already or may or may not already know
that if you have three angles that form
a line so let me draw it if you have
three angles that form a line like this
so let's say we have angle a angle B and
angle
let me draw be a little bit different
eeee and angle see just like that and
together they kind of form a you could
imagine a semicircle or they go from one
line all the way back that a B plus C
are going to be equal to 180 a plus B
plus C is going to be equal to 180
degrees they complete a 180 degree arc
now if you look at let's say this point
right here on our diagram you can see
that the angle X plus this angle right
here which I'll call it well I'll just
call it what should I call it I could
call it angle Z X plus Z plus y is going
to be equal to 180 degrees they form a
line so X plus Z plus y or maybe I
should write it as X plus y plus Z is
equal to 180 now we already know that X
plus y is equal to 90 so this is equal
to 90 so 90 plus Z is equal to 180 Z
minus or both sides of this equation
minus 90 degrees you get 180 minus 90
I just subtracting 90 from both sides so
Z is equal to 90 degrees so this is
definitely these are all 90-degree
angles inside their sides are all the
same length of C so this is a square in
the middle of this diagram now let's
take a little bit let's think a little
bit about what the area of the square is
and there's two ways there's two ways we
can come up with the area of that square
so let me draw something here so the
first easy way to think of the area of
square was to square this length is C
that length is C to figure out the area
I just met one side by the other side
it's C times C or C squared so if I want
the area of that right there it is
C squared C times C area is equal to C
squared but how else could we figure out
that area well we could figure out we
could say well it's also that would be
the area of this larger square of this
whole square over here
right - - the area of these triangles -
the area of this triangles that also
would give us the area of that inside
square so what is the area of this
outside bigger square well each of its
sides are a plus B a plus B and so you
take a plus B if you want the area you
could say a plus B times a plus B or a
plus B squared right that's the area of
the outer of the outer square but we
still to get the area of our inner
square let me the area of small square
area of small square we still have to
subtract out the area of these triangles
and what are the areas of these
triangles well the area of each of them
so we have to subtract out the area of
each of them is one half times base
times height or a base times height a be
1/2 a B that's how big that's the area
of each of these triangles now we have 1
2 3 4 of these triangles so it's 4 times
1/2 a B this is another way of getting
the area of this inside of this inside
smaller square now let's just do a
little bit of algebra we're pretty
familiar with this to essentially
simplify the right-hand side of this
equation right here so a plus B times a
plus B a times a is a squared plus 2 a B
plus B squared and then we have - what
do we have right here - to a B right 4
times 1/2 is 2 so minus 2 a B well these
cancel out - a B - 2 a B we're just left
with a squared + B squared so the area
of this inside circle which is C squared
it's also equal to a squared plus B
squared and I've just shown you a visual
proof for the Pythagorean theorem
because remember a and B were the
smaller sides of a right triangle having
C as its hypotenuse and from there we
constructed this bigger diagram
hopefully you found that fun